eux comme ce fonds euros à la fnac
voilà la pochette et un peu cassée mais
c'était avant d'en bas
vingt balles bros ouais bon moi je viens
moi j'ai 50 balles je veux pas dépenser
le plus que 40 parce que je suis alors
si tu veux moi je t'achète je te donne
dibala ouais hein et puis je te file un
pic sous là aussi qu'est ce que tu aimes
l'argent oui c'est quelque chose de très
précieux pour moi j'ai décidé d'ouvrir
un compte et bout que bien l'argent que
tu as mis sur cette route
je garde des enfants et jeunes ou pétéca
quand des gens sont partis en vacances
et je je fais les marchés tous les
samedis et puis j'arrose les jardins
sicile des gens quand ils partent ici en
vacances s'est peu mobile rapporte tout
ça oui
alors les marchés c'est 60 francs les
gardes ça dépend des faces et 15 font
défaut c'est 13 francs et les chasser la
dépend des gens alors au total sur ton
compte ça fait combien aujourd'hui au
9665 tu lui pas un pur a dit aussi je ne
défendent pas beaucoup je garde surtout
d'argent
je préfère économiser pour moi plus tard
avoir de l'argent pour mes enfants pour
moi voir une belle vie
[Musique]
on
être majeur ça veut dire avoir des
libertés donc quand on a des libertés à
13 ans ça veut dire qu'on a un compte à
la banque
alors moi j'aime l'argent mais c'est à
dire que j'aime l'argent en petites
quantités c'est à dire que quand on a
une petite quantité sur soi on aime bien
parce que on est plus libre de pouvoir
le dépenser quand on est dans la rue et
mais quand on a quand on a beaucoup
d'argent
c'est pas une honte d'avoir de l'argent
mais quand on en a beaucoup on le met
sur le compte épargne et pour moi aimer
l'argent c'est bah oui j'aime bien
l'argent les économies vont me servir à
acheter des grosses choses c'est à dire
l'année dernière je me suis acheté un
vélo et pour l'instant je suis à travers
un projet je voudrais m'acheter un
ordinateur ça me tombe bien alors
l'ordinateur que je veux le spectrum il
vaut 2000 fraude
je préférais un compte électronique à la
caisse d'epargne parce que d'abord on
est plus libre de dépenser son argent
n'a pas besoin de demander aux parents
et c'est surtout pour avoir une liberté
en plus quoi parce que quand on doit
demander aux parents à chaque fois c'est
toujours un peu la pagaille ils nous
demandent à oui pourquoi tu veux faire
ça
[Musique]
à
françois sarrat pan de la veille par
brice oui beaucoup surtout quand il fait
beau ça dépend des gens
en comptant ou furieux
[Applaudissements]
il y en a qui gagnent entre 8 et 10
seront alors en france rentrant pas pour
combien dans une journée
on peut rapporter dans 300 francs chacun
quand tu as deux tout seul c
on rigole pas assez peu marre en plus
c'est bon on est content c'est joyeux
c'est à deux ans marc est ce que tu
aimes l'argent oui beaucoup
ça gâche un peu trop
moi je m'achète trop de gaz trop j'en ai
pense que caroline aimez-vous l'argent
oui je crois que monter de façon tout le
monde émergent
quand tu peux te dire qu'on n'aime pas
l'argent c'est un peu facile c'est un
peut cracher dans la soupe
il ya une idée de profits un peu quand
même dans l'argent l'impression que l'on
peut toujours gagner plus qui est qui
est sûrement lié à une idée de travail
c'est sûr on n'a pas cette idée de
grandes fortunes on a l'idée de travail
plutôt une idée d'ailleurs assez assez
créatrice à 20minutes on a moins envie
maintenant de rentrer dans de grandes
entreprises et de suivre son bonhomme de
chemin
mais plutôt de créer son truc de lancer
son plan de lancer une idée c'est un peu
le modèle de bernard tapie qu'on a qu'on
a tous n'ont pas tous mais qu'on a un
peu dans l'esprit qui est un peu lancé
cette cette idée de création de jouer le
tout pour le tout pour essayer de gagner
de l'argent
en fait c'est l'histoire d'une petite
fille tu vas voir sa grand mère parce
qu'elle est malade et sa grand-mère à la
[ __ ] dans la forêt et alors il part pour
lui apporter des galettes de la
confiture et dans leur fort elle
rencontre un mot c'était fade août vient
l'argent que tu as mes parents me donne
50 francs tous les mois
sinon je fais à différents petits
travaux comme garder les enfants
tondre la pelouse dès qu'il ya quelque
chose comme ça une petite bricole qui me
plaît je l'achète tout de suite si quand
j'ai pas de but précis avec mon argent
de poche où je dépense tout d'un coup et
maintenant tu vas but précis oui
maintenant là j'ai envie de m'acheter
une chaîne alors qu'yves au 2400 francs
j'arrive là petit à petit sinon je me
suis acheté un ordinateur à peu près 900
francs ils étaient parents n'auraient
pas pu l'offrir
non parce que je trouve que avoir
quelques un gros cadeau comme ça c'est
faut avoir le mérite de enfin avoir eu
l'argent au fur et à mesure et la
lâcheté soi même mais c'est un effort
oui c'est un effort récompensé est ce
que tu aimes l'argent belges en marge
mais je n'aimerais pas en avoir trop
parce que comme c'est beaucoup de
projets beaucoup de rêves
j'ai besoin de rêver si j'en avais
trouverai je pourrai plus rêver maman me
donne de l'argent 50 francs par semaine
et puis aussi comme il faut un peu se
tracasser que je vais faire des
économies clef paris ses affaires j'ai
promener des chiens enfin j'ai mis une
annonce dans un magasin dans une
boulangerie puis j'ai promené aux
deschiens comme ça et ça râle pas ben
j'avais dit front de la demi-heure les
cétacés quoi et je vais pas réussir et
faire des économies mais enfin je me
suis bien amusé qu'est ce que ça
représente pour toi l'argent mais pour
moi l'argent ça représente surtout
quelque chose qui m'aide à m'amuser et
tous qui met pas ce que je peux m'amuser
sans et tout mais je crois pas je
préfère j'aime beaucoup avoir d'argent
quand j'en veux pour faire chez par
notre forêt ou pour aller
dans les foires et tout je m'éclate et
après midi après j'ai plus d'argent mais
c'est pas grave la cuisse finalement ça
stimule ou bien sa s'inquiètent
c'est inquiète au départ et je crois que
ça stimule ensuite parce qu'il ya
justement cette idée de puisqu'il n'ya
pas de puisqu'il n'a pas travaillé pour
tout le monde
on n'a qu'à se lancer nous et ouvrir
faire notre chemin
donc je crois que aux deux au départ
c'est un peu inquiété on a un peu
l'impression de se dire bon assurons
faisons des études réussissons et puis
aussi cette idée de bon puisqu'il n'y a
pas de place pour nous on va la prendre
quoi
[Musique]